Stop, Namit.
Hey, Keith, how you doing?
Good, I'm good. How are you?
All right.
Nice.
So, are things on your end?
They're okay, just...
Well, Monday being Monday, we've had some, just we've been working through some operational items, but yeah, I was...
True.
Yeah.
I was actually just sitting here doing, before you and I got together, I was getting my 20 daily minutes that I'm supposed to be spending on LinkedIn.
Ha ha ha.
commenting and liking, you know, feeding the algorithms.
Yeah, you're able to follow that?
I was mulling through and a customer that our relationship rolled up in February at Liberty Capital Bank. They were a long time customer. I mean, I was doing contract work for them before I even started my company. But they had bought, they bought a larger or a bank about the same size.
Mhm.
that had three people in their IT department and they're working with this, they're working with RSM, this ginormous MSP.
And so they decided to work with RSM going forward. And so our last day with them was on February the 6th.
Ohh.
But I was just, the current CEO at Liberty Capital Bank, he had a post and he was talking about Ben Cunningham. And Ben Cunningham is, he's still on the board, but he's the founder of the bank. And I was putting a comment in there just about how, I mean, even when the bank was still quote unquote in organization before they even open,
Mhm.
That's when I met Ben. And he just, he took a chance on me and extended opportunity to me before I even had my company. And I mean, it was, that was almost a 17 year relationship.
Right.
Mhm.
Mm.
Nice.
So it was before I joined you, I was having a few minutes of reflecting and putting in the comment just about Ben.
Mhm.
Uh, and you, it's very easy.
Oh.
Keith, as you, I'm sure you're aware, is that the voice that's in your head?
If it was a friend of yours, you probably wouldn't want to be friends with the voice that's in your head, and so...
That is.
That is such a nice thought.
It's good to take a minute and just reflect, even though the relationships come to an end, just to think about the things around here that just because Ben extended that opportunity that I was able to do, especially in 2012 when I was starting my company. So that's what I was doing before you and I got hooked up on the phone.
Yeah.
Mm.
That's that was very well said.
Nice and very true as well.
How about yourself? You okay?
Hmm.
Yep, yep. It's a hectic week though, the hectic weekend rather, since our Kam is here in India and she and Rita both, they had some really, really good sessions scheduled for us for this weekend. It was of course conducted by Rita.
Ohh.
herself, Kam, a sister, and was a good 7, 6, 7 hour session, but on both the weekends. So lots of learnings, yes, engaging and totally enlightening. It's just that it was tiring too in the end. Of course, we didn't get to sleep much, but yeah, it was good. Overall, it was good.
That's amazing.
Yep.
Really Kam and Sunny, or...
I mean, not, it's not just that they have an incredible story, but they're just, they're just really, they're just quality, they're quality people. And what they're capable of is, what they're capable of is,
Yeah.
You know, it's amazing what they deliver, what they do, how they support the people that serve their business, how they support the other companies that they serve. They're just good people.
Mhm.
Yeah.
True, true. And I mean, the kind of sessions they are conducting right now for all the other MSPs about how to grow, that's, I personally feel that's not something that everybody does, especially in this business where everything is competition. So yeah, I really admire that piece as well. So yeah, really, really happy that I was part of those sessions yesterday and the review for yesterday as well.
Right, so cool. With that said, on that note, I have shared my screen with you and since we haven't seen the data for March yet as an MBR, as a whole month of data, I'm just presenting the March data here. Nothing, not too much to showcase for April, so I'm just keeping that for the next call. We're going to talk about how things went.
for the month of March for both the individuals that we have. We jump right into the agenda, which will be the check-in, the voice of your customer, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, and recap. Really quickly, check-in, checking about Spencer and Kaila bolts. How do you think they're doing? Any?
Any feedback, anything you'd like to bring up?
Kai and Spencer, I mean, from a work perspective, you know, they're doing well. I mean, they handle A lot. They're taking reactive tickets and reactive noise, and they're helping us with, I mean, we had one of our bank customers had an outage this morning, and Spencer was able to work with somebody over the phone to get something power cycled.
We've had, we've been working refresh projects for some other customers and they've been helping me and Kris and Austin get machines profiled and data migrated and stuff out the door. So yeah.
Mhm.
And.
Nice, nice. Good to hear that. And Spencer was recently blessed with a child. I'm sure you know about that. So yeah, he's handling work and family both simultaneously, so I'm happy how he's juggling between both things and he's still delivering.
I know.
I would say. So good thing he's able to do that.
Even even on a even on a disrupted sleep schedule.
True, true.
We all know what that's like when you bring that baby home from the hospital. You're eating, you're eating, you play for a few minutes, you're changing diapers, and then you're sleeping again.
Yeah, exactly.
True, very true. We've all seen that. All right. So on that note, very quickly highlights the daily board reviews. Daily board reviews are in place for both engineers, ensuring alignment on open tickets, priorities, and blockers every morning. AI-powered collaboration, collaborative brainstorming sessions have commenced involving.
both engineers and AI tools, accelerating resolution and knowledge sharing, level of progress. Kaila and Spencer are actively working on their level of programs, building skills aligned to client needs and career growth. That said, there's only one action tracker that's currently open and it's going to be in progress. Kaila and Spencer are working on their level ups. ITBD recommended KPIs is something that we've brought up and prior to me, the other TT.
the other POC who was aligned with you guys has also shared this information with you. I'm going to just skip this slide now. We'll jump directly on the performance analysis and we'll talk about their utilization first. We'll talk about both the individuals. Again, this is across the month of March. We've divided the whole month of March in five different weeks from 2 to 6, 9 to 13, 16 to 20, 23rd to 27 and 30th.
to 31st. Again, for both the individuals, the first week, both of them worked for three days. There were two PTOs for both the individuals. Despite of that, their billable utilization was 86.3% for Spencer and 83.1% for Kaila. In the second week and 3rd and 4th, they all worked for all the five days. So they're sitting at 75.8% in the first week.
For Spencer, 52%, a bit lower as compared to Spencer. That's Kaila I'm talking about. Then for March 16th to 28th, Spencer sitting at 68.5, Kaila at 66.4, both around the same lines. In the third week, that is rather 4th in total, March 23rd to March 27th, Spencer
dipped a bit, sitting at 56.4 and Kaila also, there was a dip in her utilization from 66 to 56.2, but then they did deliver in the last week as well, again, just two days, but their utilization was better than the previous one. Spencer sitting at 64% and Kaila at 75%. So overall, Spencer.
Spencer averaged 69.5 the whole month. There were two PTOs as well. A strong 86% when fully available. As we can see for Kaila, she averaged 64.4%, 3 PTOs in total for her. Weeks with full attendance show improved billable trajectory. Both engineers exceed target and full availability weeks and excluding PTO weeks combined active.
day billable average sits at 73% for both. Otherwise, overall, considering all the PTOs and all the number of days that they worked, their average overall combined is 67%. But how do you think this number looks like? Of course, yes, it's below the target, but still would like to hear your views.
Really, the 60% is the number that I personally look for. I was a little surprised to see that that week of the 23rd through the 27th would be the lowest utilization, just because I wasn't at work that week. I would have thought that they would have.
Mm.
Okay.
Mhm.
Mm.
I would have thought that they would have had far more to do with me being gone. But yeah, no other question, no other question.
More.
Okay.
Okay, all right. And with that said, I mean, yes, probably because I can see the number of tickets in that particular week as well. It's comparatively, in fact, on the lower side, the one, the number of tickets that they've closed. So I'll again, go week on week. The first week, Spencer closed 26th and Kaila closed 40. The target for both of Spencer in the first week was 24th and he closed 26th.
Again, this is based on 8 tickets per day. Kaya's target was 24 and she closed 40. So both of them, as you can see, there's a check mark. That means they maintained the target for that particular week. Week 2, Spencer closed 32, Kaila closed 39. Week 3, 40 for Spencer, 41 for Kaila. Good, good rise there.
The week that you were talking about, the week that you were out, Spencer sat at 68, sorry, 38 closures and Kaila at 31 lowest so far. So yeah, probably the volume was pretty low for that week. And then last week, with just two days, Spencer closed 24, met the target, Kaila closed 18 as well, and she did.
met the target as well. Overall, they closed a total of 329 tickets, which is on an average, again, combined 8.4 tickets per day. But your thoughts?
I don't know that I have any additional thoughts. The the data's the data's good and there.
They're both hard at it every day.
Mm.
Awesome. Perfect. Good to hear that. I think that would be it from the performance perspective. Yeah, rest of the slides are just information talking about the AI by design, something that we already talked about, something that Sunny has is strongly working on. The other products that we offer, Team GPS are in grown product, which is pretty popular by now. And yeah, in case you need.
to know any information about it. There's a QR code there in case you want to see a demo for it. Again, you can go through the link and get to see that there's an interactive video uploaded by Sunny himself for this. But yeah, again, if you ever want a demo to be scheduled for you, we can get that done by our CX team as well. And that would be it. I will be stopping the share and.
We'll open the forum for anything you'd like to bring up. Anything else you'd like to bring up, Matt?
Keith, I don't have...
I don't have any other new business, man. I just like getting filled in on just on the metrics. And I wish that when Spencer, I didn't even, I didn't even know that he and his wife were expecting.
I would have liked to have thought that we were far enough along to where he would have told me what they had going and he was going to have some planned time away. I'm just glad that everything went okay when she had to go to the hospital that day.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Things were not very easy as well.
So that's, I'm glad they're glad they're at home and doing okay.
He did mention, yeah, they had to go through some complications and I'm glad they were able to handle it. And yeah, I'm glad nothing got hampered on your end as well when it comes to operations. So think about all, I mean, it just ended well, thankfully. And yeah, in case, in case there's anything that.
Yeah.
But...
Comes up or if there's anything for me, just please do connect to let me know, Matt.
Okay.
Right, perfect.
Well, if you see, if you see Sushant, tell him you talk to me. I'll catch up with him, I hope, sometime soon.
Ha ha.
Absolutely. Will do. Will surely do. Thank you so much, Matt. Thanks for joining in. Bye. Bye.
Alright, see ya.